the sketch show is hilarious and i know
you've been doing this for a while
you've you've
you you did uh impressions you still do
impressions yes
yes you do uh barack obama uh president
obama impressed
this is true a little bit of uh you know
we
keegan michael key the other uh actor
and i you know we sort of
have a thing about obama which is huge
he's like the best thing to happen to
black nerds
ever you know because how was that
before him it was basically urkel it was
urkel and uh
you know the gay guy from revenge of the
nerds we like to uh
that's it that's all they had that's
something yeah so we like to shout out
to him every now and then
so there's a couple pieces that we do
with him and uh okay so i'm curious what
is your
i i've talked to impressionists many
times and they'll tell me that they
how they key into a certain person that
they're doing impression of
and there are certain ways that you get
in to understand how to do them what's
the trick for president obama yeah
it really started as a kid or a teenager
going up you know you do method man i'm
from new york
so i met the man there's always you know
how many
how many blunts can we mix in a stoop
you know he would say something like
that
and then i got into mad tv and uh you
know started learning more impressions i
ended up doing a montel williams on mad
tv
uh and montel always you know toward the
end he will always just be
you know talking about we are talking to
women who are
abused by dolphins at this point
you know a guy really didn't have a lot
to talk about there
so at some point it just it occurred to
me that uh
uh obama is actually uh montel williams
minus
method man
that's the complicated format can we
well that's that's it pretty much it's
it's right here
and uh all right
uh thank you but you know the situation
at hand
you know is something we need to take a
good a better look at
you know well he's also one of those
that's very good he's very
pleased he's very uh
it does seem like you and you're
capturing it that president obama takes
his time it takes his time and uh if you
know if you want to if you're doing an
obama impression
you know he'll he'll uh actually think
uh before he talks
and do that sometimes he needs to
take a little bit of a break
now you uh have had some fun putting
president obama in
kind of fun scenarios yeah we take we
take them all over
uh one of our favorite things to talk
about though is just what what what
obama was like in college
because he uh that that just makes a
slap because you know he's obviously you
know
he's studious and uh hardworking
hardworking guy but i always picture
that he's a little bit more like styles
from teen wolf i don't know if you
remember this character this is like a
16 year old reference that's okay except
because so you know we always picture
he's you know a little bit more all
right we got a party tonight
oh he's running he's running uh oh you
know we're running a fertile
sure that you know this time you know
one percent of the population doesn't
smoke 99 of the week
these are the issues we need to
at 0 800 hours we uh you know destroyed
the r.a tiffany with a predator drone
[Laughter]
you know now what about you on the show
you do
every now and then there's a character
that comes along i think i don't even
know how they these guys arrived at that
you do a baby
forest whitaker character not forest
whitaker
baby forest whitaker yeah this is like
the most absurd thing in the world
really
uh yeah enforcement one of my favorite
actors he's just he's
he's such a sort of has such an awkward
presence and he's so menacing in his
films that we ended up sort of asking
ourselves the question you know what
what was baby forest whitaker like what
must it have been like to uh babysit
force whitaker we did a very
elaborate special effect where we put my
head on a
toddler's body and uh
i don't want to spoil the the uh thing
for you but
you know just to put it simply this line
does make it in which is like gaga
you know
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
a lullaby go to sleep
go to sleep no put my name in there go
to sleep
forest girl
i like i like it personally
ridiculous yeah yeah that's so funny
that's your favorite
that'll be my favorite yeah